I think when you ignore the market
dynamics and ignore what the market can
tell you about these things you do so at
your peril and you're inviting
unanticipated consequences that could be
worse than the problem you're trying to
solve hi i'm dan hayes with reason TV
today we are joined by author rob cellco
it's the author most recently of young
world rising how youth technology and
entrepreneurship are changing the world
from the bottom up rob is also a
business consultant and contributor to
the website Fast Company Rob thanks for
joining us thanks great to be here can
you define the term young world and give
us an overview sort of a broad argument
of what your book is about sure of the
6.7 billion people on earth right now
more than half of them are under the age
of 30 and the largest number of those
live in underdeveloped countries for the
most part or emerging economies like
India and China as we move toward
mid-century the difference between the
aging developed world and the young
developing world is going to accentuate
and I see a lot of possibilities for
discovery of talent in this young world
and so these folks who have grown up
with this technology that's part of the
argument as folks have grown up with
this technology they're used to it and
they're using it in their everyday lives
as opposed to that older generation
who's not sure and we've seen that here
in the US and in other industrialized
countries over the last 25 years because
you know we're at the front edge of this
stuff so we're the where the fraud
that's been boiling in the tank
elsewhere in the world a lot of these
technologies are not only relatively
newly arrived but they're arrived at a
much farther state of development and
younger people are taking to social
networks to mobile communication to
these new technologies that have been so
disruptive here in the US in really
interesting ways in these younger parts
of the world and as technology access
increases driven partly by market forces
I think we're going to see that dynamic
accelerate you start the book with a
story of a young guy named Sue Haas
gopinath in Bangalore India what is his
story and how is it sort of
representative of your argument in this
book so sue house is great he was a 14
years old young kid in
from humble background and he started
working after school at a cyber cafe
taught himself to do web development and
started a business for himself creating
websites for businesses in the u.s.
particularly small manufacturers that
had an email address but no website so
he would email these folks and say I'm
mr. gopinath from India I'd like to
order a 10,000 of your widgets please
direct me to your website and they would
say we don't have a website but we have
a catalog and you'd say I'm sorry you
don't meet my supply standards by the
way would you like to buy a website and
uh you know it's it sounds a little
shady but he is now studied in Indian
marketing programs for the ingenuity of
this plan he's grown his company into a
global company he's in 12 different
countries it's a multi-million dollar
concern and he is the youngest member of
the World Economic Forum so he's sipping
champagne in Davos with Bill Clinton and
Warren Buffett but he started as a 14
year old and a cybercafe basically and
he's only 22 now and he's and he's
looking for the next thing to do because
you know he's done with that and that's
incredible so you said you'd like to
look particularly at the unique
relationship between youth technology
adoption and the willingness to take
entrepreneurial risk so what what is the
relationship there well there's a couple
of things one thing is that the spread
of Technology and particularly high tech
business models or much less
capital-intensive so you can start a
business the way sue Haas did with
almost no investment except your own
expertise because you've already got the
platform to reach a global market to tap
a global talent base so that sort of
changes the economics a little bit makes
the entry costs a lot lower and also the
rewards are higher because for the
people that have the talent to do this
especially in developing countries it's
like you know you don't have to work in
the t shirt factory you don't have to
work in the in the mind you know if you
can figure this out you can earn a
decent living for yourself in you know
dignified working conditions and give
employment to other people and sort of
move society forward in you know better
in different ways and that's if you have
accessed the technology that allows that
to happen absolutely not just the
technology but also the skills and
know-how in the book you suggest that
this young world is more adept at
figuring out market-based solutions to
social problem
so can you kind of talk about this idea
of social entrepreneurship and how
that's how that's addressed in the book
sure it's kind of an interesting concept
because here in the US and in industrial
economies we have these concepts of
social entrepreneurship which is you
know grant funded nonprofit that's
trying to do good in the world and then
there's corporate social responsibility
which is a commercial business that's
putting their own you know out of the
goodness of their heart trying to solve
a solve a problem elsewhere in the world
the the idea of commercial prosperity
can't be separated from social progress
and let me give you an example like in
India Infosys the enormously successful
IT services company there spends a huge
amount of money training young people
even graduates of good schools to get
them up to this level of global
employability that they would have that
they need to be effectively competitive
but they don't stop adjust the elite
institutions they actually deliberately
broaden their search because they know
that there's a social impact of picking
some kid out of a small rural college
you know as one of the the chosen few
that's going to get to work in Infosys
goes back home becomes an ambassador for
knowledge economy becomes an ambassador
for entrepreneurship and the VP of
Infosys said to me if we stop doing that
if we narrow that search for talent and
and cut off that access to opportunity
the whole India story is over and she
said the India story not the Infosys
story and you know because Infosys sees
its role in the indian economy in
broader terms than just its own
prosperity and it recognizes that if it
can't deploy its own resources to make
progress on these issues its commercial
success as a private business is in
peril and you seem optimistic about
technology in general and technology in
the future what's your grand sort of
utopian vision going for it and 20 years
what are we going to be doing that we
can't do now well i would say technology
utopianism isn't my orientation I'm
actually rather pessimistic about the
general direction of things I look at
technology is the only way we're going
to solve these problems because there's
a real deficit of public will to address
common challenges right now so our best
ho
is to by broadening a conversation out
to a billion people makes it more likely
that we're going to find that one in a
billion idea because that's that's the
one we need so talk a little bit about
your politics you've kind of argued that
there's a top-down hierarchical sort of
archaic system in place and that this
young world is going to provide a
bottom-up you know way of exchanging
information can you kind of talk about
that sounds a little libertarian can you
kind of talk about your personal
politics and the politics of this book
yeah i mean i think that large
organizations serve the 20th century
pretty well and because centralized
hierarchies or a good way of organizing
large organizations to get stuff done
move into the 21st century in these
networks start to offer us other options
about how to manage organizations
organizations that can be a little bit
more nimble that can be a little bit
more responsive to the local needs and
local cultures and local desires of the
people that are doing them so you're not
forcing people a choice between you know
you either take the big solution or no
solution you know we can actually
customize and so I think that is not
only you know a good way to run a
business is a good way to solve social
problems and I do feel deeply that there
are these social problems we have a
common responsibility to fix them but we
need to look at market-based mechanisms
for making those solutions happen in
ways that are relevant to real people so
you mentioned before you're more of a
progressive guy but you look for these
market-based solutions to solve the
problems I think when you ignore the
market dynamics and ignore what the
market can tell you about these things
you do so at your peril and you're
inviting unanticipated consequences that
could be worse than the problem you're
trying to solve at the same time if you
only pay attention to the mechanism and
not to the larger issue of what is it
we're trying to do what outcomes we're
trying to produce you know you create a
very efficient road to nowhere so we
have to we have to get beyond that
dichotomy because our problems are too
big for that kind of thinking so lastly
why should somebody read this book if
you're a young entrepreneur you're going
to find some really great ideas some
really inspiring stories of people that
are making great solutions out of almost
nothing
if you're a business leader you really
need to understand what's going on in
these parts of the world emerging
markets are where the growth are or
where the growth is and there's a lot of
opportunities to engage with these young
world partners and to understand the
sources of young world competition
before it arrives in our shores that's
great well thanks so much for joining us
Rob I enjoyed talking with you if you
want to learn more about Rob's book
visit young world rising calm and for
recent TV i'm dan hayes